[Música]
como estábamos hablando con álvaro
cordero vamos a seguir con el tema del
icono de marilyn monroe cuando se
cumplieron ya 60 años de su muerte a los
36 años de vida que tenía la actriz
pocas facetas quedan por ser reveladas
de su vida trágica y la muerte también
el mito sin duda sigue siendo fascinante
para muchos para ello nos acompaña en el
estudio hugo chaparro valderrama
escritor y crítico cinematográfico autor
de varios libros entre ellos marilyn
monroe en cuerpo y alma gracias hugo por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 y pues también nos acompaña
nuestro cronista de historia álvaro
cordero que nos está dando todo este
contexto de la diadema del módulo pero
hubo quiero empezar preguntándole que
tenia marilyn monroe que no teníamos
otras actrices de esa época
marilyn monroe tenía algo que para ella
fue claustrofóbico que fue el sexo y el
sexo la desespero hasta unos puntos muy
neurosis antes que como decía álvaro le
tocó tomar muchos los barbitúricos
soportar las burlas permanentes de la
misoginia de la época y yo creo que sí
marilyn estuviera viva hoy en día sería
una de las primeras protagonistas del
mito y las demandas contra los acosos
masculinos porque lo sufrió desde su
infancia fue abusada fue vituperada
y hay algo que hay que aclarar
en este momento que se olvida y es una
crisis cultural de la época y es que las
ppl y negras para los norteamericanos
eran astutas y la rue wiertz eran
estúpidas y para muchos el cóctel de
estupidez de marilyn monroe se cifraba
en sus nalgas de literalmente tanto así
que en japón
fue rotulada como la honorable dama de
las marcas bamboleantes y todo eso le
daría mucho a ella porque ella quería
ser una actriz desde verdad no ser
reconocida por su manera de caminar ni
por su cuerpo ni por su actitud
hipersexual inventada por los estudios
además y por su carrera como modelo pero
bueno esa es la crueldad de hollywood
con sus estrellas y eso fue lo que la
marcó bien ha cambiado mucho además lo
bueno en el chaparro bueno marilyn
monroe alcanzó un nivel de fama como
prácticamente nadie alcanzó a nivel
global usted considera que esta fama
influyó positiva o negativamente en
marilyn monroe
negativamente porque ella
como tú lo señalaba en introducción
quería ser antes que todo una actriz
cuando ella se case con arthur miller el
país es concierto porque era
prácticamente de nuevo la historia de la
bella y la bestia' pero en clave del
cerebro y la carne y una y otra vez ella
quería ser respetada es muy triste la
última entrevista que había concedido la
revista 'life' bridget merriman le pidió
que por favor
no se burlará ella como habían hecho
todos los periodistas en el transcurso
de su carrera y es una historia muy
deprimente porque
también lo señalaba si ya hizo muchas
comedias pero le interesaba hacer drama
y mostrar que tenía talento entonces
lo que la catapultó al estrellato
maldito en los años 50 que fue su década
de esplendor fue demostrar que el sexo
tiene una forma de mostrarse divertida
juguetona
desparpajada
esa fue también su uso condena porque la
encasilló en lo que yo llamo que es la
claustrofobia de su personaje ella decía
he vivido toda mi vida interpretando a
marilyn monroe pero quien salió ser
también como lo comentábamos con álvaro
en la introducción de nuestro tema la
una de la fuerte es el polémicas de su
vida no giró en torno a la relación que
tuvo con young que ni su hermano bobby
que ni cómo era la relación realmente
que mantenía marilyn monroe con ellas
ese es un caso fascinante como yo lo
considero uno de los grandes misterios
criminales del siglo 20 sí porque claro
imagínate es la gran estrella del sexo
de hollywood en una sociedad tan
conservadora como la norteamericana
relacionada con el presidente con el
fiscal del país eso es un cóctel
ingobernable para cualquier persona que
quiera tratar de tener serenidad con su
vida
la doble moral siempre
evidencia que se critica en público lo
que se disfruta en privado y le caso el
presidente que ni por supuesto cuando
ella fue a cantarle el happy verde en el
mes square garden es muy doloroso
también las carcajadas del público
cuando ella está cantando y ella lo
estaba haciendo de corazón el vestido
con el que entró que casi no podía
caminar porque estaba súper apretado
pero eso condujo a que el ministerio no
se pueda solucionar seguramente los
archivos seguirán desclasificados algún
día no lo sabemos
que el misterio hay detrás el caso se
reabrió hace hace algún tiempo para
tratar de develar el misterio pero
obviamente el cinismo del poder siempre
tiene tentáculos largos que esconden
esos misterios y muy triste como le
decía a una mujer muy burlaban o al
verte
y además yo le quería preguntar
si en todo esto además había un factor
político porque hay fuentes que señalan
que marilyn monroe estaba cercana a
determinados círculos de izquierdas del
partido comunista en eeuu y que eso pudo
influir a que determinados sectores del
estado en eeuu también rechazarán su
relación con los kennedy es esto cierto
o no y yo creo que
lo que decías de la rumorología se
acerca mucho a este tema político porque
arthur miller cuando ellos empiezan a
tener su relación es llamado por el
comité de actividades antiamericanas que
veían un comunista en cualquier esquina
del país y persiguieron a muchos
escritores entre ellos a miller y eso
nunca se lo perdonaron las mentes
bienpensantes del país
aún así pues tenía unas relaciones
también que extremaron la la suspicacia
no por ejemplo se dice que fue amate
frank sinatra entonces también hay
estado la mafia italiano involucrada
y quien estaba en el centro de todo este
huracán pues una mujer
con un corazón muy delicado con una
personalidad muy buena era muy brutal
izada por su época pero en unos
contextos de poder que ya no los podía
manejar que los empezó a sufrir en
trenton century fox que fue el primer
estudio en el que ya trabajó donde su
gran productor darwin sang la humillaba
permanentemente llega se defendía y era
otra forma del trato político no todo
termina siendo política pero en el caso
de la política profesional de los
kennedy y de esa suspicacia de si era
simpatizante o no de los comunistas pues
también puede tener otro arista de este
caso es curioso además para como como
marilyn monroe pareces una víctima de
todos los hombres que la rodeaba
básicamente no es algo que me llama
especialmente la atención claro y todo
lo que sufrió y como también digamos
siempre estaba ante todo con una sonrisa
tratando de pues estar bien presentada
ante su público pero realmente fue una
vida muy sufrida la que tuvo marino si
es una historia típicamente
norteamericana no como las muertes
tempranas janis joplin billie holliday y
las mujeres que han abierto senderos
y abrir esos senderos la historia se los
ha cobrado en el sentido en que se los
agradece pero en su momento la muerte la
acercó entonces era una circunstancia
muy dolorosa hugo antes de ir
finalizando nuestra conversación por
supuesto quiero hablar a los misterios
que rodean la muerte de marilyn monroe
durante décadas que pues todavía están
digamos sin resolver pero hasta qué
punto cree usted que puede ser
cuestionado la muerte por suicidio
yo creo que es incluso la más
acertada aunque hay muchas dudas por
ejemplo solo por citar una anécdota
rápidamente el policía que llegó en esa
madrugada al apartamento donde vivía
marimorena en los ángeles le causa mucha
curiosidad que la ama de llaves de ella
tan pronto dijo el policía aprendiera la
lavadora son detalles que pueden ser
insignificantes que son naturales de la
vida doméstica pero que estaba haciendo
esa señora se preguntó el policía nunca
se resolvió y se encontraron las
pastillas y hay algo que hay que anotar
y es la manera como encontraron el
cadáver y ella estaba boca abajo desnuda
bajo una sábana con las pastillas al
lado era un hábito muy frecuente en
hollywood de esencia que para soportar
hollywood había que tomar pastillas para
subir para bajar permanentemente la
tolera sufría ella en el caso de ella
subió y quedó permanentemente terminada
en el cielo de la pantalla
cinematográfica donde la vemos hoy en
día y sigue siendo un misterio que en mi
caso sólo se resuelve en la pantalla
cuando disfrutamos de sus películas
y rápidamente álvaro y hubo también el
legado que deja en 20 segundos el legado
que deja en memoria la dignidad
ultrajada de la mujer que hay que
cuestionar permanentemente pero vencida
con algo que era su fortaleza un gran
talento cinematográfico